For this question, you need to create the data frame
that would give us the data to construct this plot. Here's
how I would go about constructing the code. First, I'll
load the dplyr package and then I'm just going to leave myself
a comment that I'm going to chain these functions together. So
I'm using this symbol. I'm going to save my data frame as
pf.fc by age gender, and I'm going to work from my existing
data frame and group it. So, here's my first chain command,
and I'm going to group by age and gender. Now, I'm going to
summarize getting the mean friend count, the median friend count, and
n, the number of people in each group. Now, summarize will
remove one layer of grouping when it runs, so we'll remove
the gender layer. So, we need to ungroup one more
time to remove the age layer and finally I'll arrange my
data frame by age. Now, it looks like that I have
everything, but I actually forgot to filter or subset the data.
I could use the subset command but I'm actually going to show you
the filter command. I'll filter the data so that I remove any people
that have a gender marked as NA and then, I just need
to remember to chain that together with the rest of the functions. Alright,
let's run this code and see if our data frame looks good. It
looks like I actually forgot to run my library first, so let me
do that. We have our new data frame up here, so let's print
out some of the rows to make sure we're right. I'll hit out a
couple of the first rows to the console, and
I can see that I have my groups split
by age and gender, the mean friend count, the
median friend count and n, the number of groups.